each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi this is rajesh from school of
information systems at singapore
management university today we're going
to do the third lecture in the mobile
and pervasive technology series we're
going to talk about location and context
and these are fundamental issues to
anything that you want to do in the
mobile and pervasive space and let me
explain to you why first we have the
location problem and we have two
different subsets of this problem in the
space we have problem one which is about
the user himself where am i what am i
doing you know am I in redmond recording
a lecture am I in Beijing recording a
lecture where where am I locator you
know you have to be able to
differentiate whether I'm in the US
where them in China whether I'm in a
particular room or whether I'm on a
particular Street and to do this you
actually need local information you need
to know something about the area in and
you need a couple of the global map so
that you have perspective or where the
guy might be in the future but that's
only problem one we then have problem to
which is where are the people most
notably where my friends where my
colleagues or where the people I don't
want to meet where a day right now and
for that you actually meet their local
information now this obviously is
privacy and security implications which
I'll not cover in this lecture but will
be covered in a subsequent lecture for
example if you want to know where your
best friend is located that might be
easier because your breast friend
actually knows you and is willing to
share its location with you what happens
you want to know where your enemy is
located that can't be done that easily
I'll say you wanted to know where your
coworkers are located that may also be
quite tricky to pull off and that with
all this information you need one map
they can cover everybody and that can
get tricky people are very
geographically dispersed if everyone is
within a small vicinity a small map
covers it but if everyone is located in
different countries one map that shows
everyone might not give you enough
detail to actually know for sure where
people are located but what can you do
with this right one obvious and nice
solutions to say a GPS will solve ever
I just use GPS you will figure out the
answers to everything unfortunately the
answer is no gps does not solve the
problem GPS is strictly a read-only
system at least for commercial and
private use and it doesn't actually tell
you where your friends are located
because GPS as I said it's read-only
your friends know where they are located
you know where you're located using GPS
but for you to send your information
your friends and vice versa you still
need a third party service where you
upload that information everything you
see in the movies where they use GPS to
track evildoers and other people is just
wrong GPS cannot be used for that you
need a third party cellular network
service or something where you can
actually send your GPS coordinates and
then have that be sent to you GPS by
itself will not do what you think it
does another major problem GPS is that
it does not work indoors and with the
proliferation of large malls and you
know shopping centers and office
buildings etc it's becoming increasingly
important to know where you are inside a
building but GPS doesn't work inside a
building because the GPS receivers
cannot see the satellites so we need
another solution inside buildings then
we also have issues with GPS hardware
it's more expensive than other solutions
but this is becoming better GPS also
uses a lot of energy but this is also
becoming better for a better description
of GP of the GPS system you can look up
references like Wikipedia et cetera we
then have other alternatives no so what
if we cannot use GPS know what else can
we do well fortunately there are other
solutions that people use we have things
where we can use Wi-Fi access points now
Wi-Fi is the 802 11 gb GN standard that
most of you have set up at home you know
this is your personal wireless network
that almost everyone uses at home to get
internet connectivity and in most urban
areas it is not uncommon to see a lot of
access points even if you cannot connect
them because they are protected by
security passwords but just knowing what
access points you see tells you a lot
about where you are located there are
many commercial companies like skyhook
that use this to
by very accurate positioning information
for companies like Apple Google etc you
can also use your cell tower ID which
cell towers are the things that serve
your cellular signal whether it is 3g
LTE or GP GPRS in some countries and
these cell towers are in very well known
locations they do not move because they
are physical physical structures that
are connected into the ground if you
know where the cell towers are located
and you know what you can which cell
towers you can see you have a very good
idea where you are look where you are
based in the world now your accuracy is
not that great in certain situations but
it's still better than nothing it will
definitely be able to tell you I'm in
Seattle vs I'm in San Francisco and that
may be good enough for many applications
now given that you have your location
what can you do with it it turns out the
location by itself while powerful it's
not good enough you also need to know
something else before applications can
do stuff for you and this is known as
context now what do I mean by context
context is a catch-all word that refers
to anything and everything that a person
is doing now what are some examples of
context first we have what are you doing
example I'm giving a lecture right now
but what are you doing you might be
listening to this you might be drinking
coffee you might be sitting down you
might be standing up these are all
important pieces of information for
software that is trying to do stuff for
you you then have where you are this is
location right and this is a very
important part of context next you have
who is with you this is turns out to be
quite important for things like social
networking applications or even email
you may not want certain types of email
to come to you when you're with people
who are not allowed to see those emails
or even know that you're getting them
for knowing who is around you and who is
actually associating with you can be
really powerful next what are you
thinking this is actually really useful
by incredibly hard to obtain for example
if you are thinking I would like to go
for Chinese food now a restaurant
recommendation system that tells you
about Mexican food may not be that
useful but how do you actually convey
your thoughts to the applications
what are you wearing this could be
important for certain types of
applications like fashion apps what are
you carrying no do you have a camera
with you you have a cell phone based on
what devices you're carrying certain
choices and certain activities become
feasible while others become infeasible
and finally what you plan to do you know
what are your longer-term plans or your
shot diploma plants are you planning to
take a break are you planning to work on
a paper by planning to watch a movie all
of these things impact what applications
become useful to you and what
recommendations or choices are most
appropriate for what you want to do
right now now what is a problem in
collecting context it seems like we will
like all these things but unfortunately
they are really really hard to collect
right how do you measure contact how do
you know that you have what it is that
you are trying to clear how do you know
that you know for example what are you
thinking how do you know that this is
what I'm really thinking right now and
that I'm not lying to you or making
stuff up unfortunately don't do a very
good job with this we do it really
really poorly we can ask people but then
we have no way of guaranteeing that what
we actually found out it's actually
correct so what can you do if you cannot
measure accurately well one fatalistic
approach is to give up just say yeah we
can't do it so we won't use it at all
unfortunately this is not the correct
solution even with half decent context
you can still make very very good
applications they can still do a lot of
amazing things so you can do three
things you can approximate the context
can info I can use what we call
heuristics I will cover all of these in
turn in the next few slides so in the
broad spectrum of context approximation
yeah a couple of approaches one is to
guess you just make up something you
know say the question is what am I
thinking you go yeah he's thinking about
dogs you just make a guess and the
benefits of this is it's very simple to
build you can just pick anything you
want but the disadvantage of this is
it's usually disastrous in practice you
are very very unlikely to be correct so
any system that's built that that is
trying to help the user that is built
built on top of guesswork
likely will be a disaster next you can
ask the user to tell you you know every
time you need to know like what am I
thinking you put up a big text box a
what are you thinking right now or if
you need to know where the user is
located you put our big tex bones they
type in your location the benefits of
this is this is always correct correct
in inverted commas because frequently
users do not even know what they are
thinking or what they are doing and what
they are carrying or they may be giving
you wrong results because they are tired
of the system asking them the
disadvantage is this is very very
annoying for the user if you are used a
system that's always asking you for
inputs like what are you doing where
you're going this will be a disaster
there are many many notable examples
from history one of them is the
paperclip that arrived in office for
example and there are others similar
systems that have really annoyed users
so please don't do this one very good
method of figure out context is to just
say the user was doing this ten minutes
ago I assume he'll be doing the same
thing ten minutes from now turns out
this actually works really well in
practice if you actually train the
system properly if you have enough data
but what the users patterns are you can
make a very good system just by assuming
that what the user did in the past is
what he's going to do right now the big
disadvantage of this is that if the user
actually changes what they are doing the
system takes a long time to react but if
the users changes are small this is
still better than nothing and indeed
more systems that try to figure out that
try to use context do this a lot they
actually assume that you are going to do
what they have seen you doing in the
past other methods you can do is you can
do what they call table lookups which is
basically to create what they call a
decision tree you a priority decide you
know if I see this situation this is
what the answer is going to be if I see
this situation this is what the answer
is going to be for example if the user
is sitting in the chair I assume that
he's doing work the user is standing on
by assume he's going home things like
this you make decisions in before the
system starts and you put them in a
table lookup the pro is that you can
have a very rich set of responses you
can create a case for almost everything
the disadvantage is that it's not
adaptable at all you if you make a
mistake the user stuck with it or if you
see a situation that your table doesn't
have entry for you might be you might
have nothing to do which would also
annoy the user what you can do next then
is to use any of the previous schemes
but you incorporate machine learning
techniques you know to fill in the gaps
so you put in learning algorithm so I
says you know we did this previously but
then the user said was wrong for maybe
you should change our system or change
our lookups or maybe we should add a new
entry into our table maybe we should
assume something different for the user
behavior the pro is that theoretically
this is much better right in theory if
we could predict the user behavior and
learn from other users doing we should
do an amazing job however in practice
this doesn't really work that well in
practice because the machine learning
algorithms are really hard to use and it
turns out that they're kind of slowing
in practice when you actually use them
it takes a long time to converge and by
that time the users already either
really annoyed or not using the
application anymore what one final thing
you could do is to use what they call
static prediction tables which are table
lookups but you have user intervention
if something goes wrong when you're not
sure about something you ask the user
and this actually works quite well if
you set it up properly if you have a
good set of predefined actions that you
know are correct plus you know which are
the cases where the user has to give you
input it works really well it's a
trade-off between doing things
automatically and asking the user for
help the disadvantage is that the user
must understand a lot more things they
need to understand what the system is
doing for them and understand where it's
going to break down there are many
examples or mobile applications and
pervasive applications that fall into
this category where they do a really
good job in certain cases but when
they're not sure they ask to use it and
it turns out that this might be one of
the best things to do in practice
because the user space is so rich that
is hard to predict everything and with
that I come to the end of this lecture
and I hope at the end of lecture you
have a good understanding of what is
location why is what are the two
problems that we need to solve in
location namely first to figure out
where you are and next to figure where
your friends are we under
then that location is not solved by GPS
that there still are a lot of problems
then we took a broader look at what is
the idea behind context context is what
makes all mobile and pervasive
applications go without this you do not
know what the user wants and you can't
do anything and then we've seen the
context comes in many shapes and sizes
and that is really really hard to
actually use contacts in applications
and I went we went through a couple of
examples of ways you could use it and
cover the pros and cons of each of them
so hopefully at the end of this lecture
you have a better understanding of how
to use context and when it breaks down
and why this space is still full of
opportunities thank you very much